aujourd'hui vous avez des classes
populaires qui subissent la
mondialisation dans tous les sens qui
subissent austérité salariale mais qui
vont tenir des discours assez proches de
ceux finalement de l'élite mondialisée
du style quand on veut on peut
le travail c'est quelque chose de très
bien qui vous permettent de devenir
riche fac qui prennent en compte
vraiment il faut plus de liberté faut
payer moins d'impôts etc
c'est à dire quand vous discutez parfois
avec des chauffeurs hubert et vous vous
dire il faut baisser la fiscalité mais
la réalité c'est que lorsqu'il leur
fiscalité est très élevé mais elle est
aussi élevé parce que la plateforme qui
les emploient ne paie pas d'impôts en
france donc la vraie question n'est pas
la question de plus ou moins à pau la
question c'est une question de justice
fiscale
20 % d'impôt sur un chauffeur rubber
c'est énorme quand il sait que sa
plateforme en paie pas les charges que
l'on va payer peut-être un un patron de
café vont être énormes quand ils voient
que juste en face de lui vous avez
starbucks qui qui qui n'en paient pas
donc donc on est vraiment sûr voilà sur
un problème plutôt de justice fiscale
que de questions de fiscalité de niveau
de fiscalité
la fiscalité est un problème qui est
surtout relatif me semble-t-il avec des
gros qui en payent très peu et qui en
paie de moins en moins je me suis alors
que nicolas sarkozy quand il se
présentait en 2012
il s'était rendu compte qu'un certain
nombre d'entreprises ne paient pas
d'impôts il voulait faire un impôt
spécial qui l'avait qualifié l'impôt
total
à l'époque oui vous avez dit du cac 40
qui ont des pressions fiscales beaucoup
plus faible que certaines pme et ça
c'est un vrai problème et vous avez
aujourd'hui les multinationales qui ne
paie pas d'impôts en france quand
d'autres des petites pme en paix c'est
ça en vrai le nerf de la guerre c'est
pas de baisser la fiscalité pour tous
puisque même en baissant la fiscalité
finalement amazon aura toujours plus
davantage qu'une librairie du coin c'est
de faire en sorte que amazon paye plus
d'impôt que la librairie du coin
[Musique]